you may just have a very angelic face
and be really good at lying and looking
at somebody for clues now that is the
most fascinating thing I think I've
heard from you all day
it's kah if you're from Boston are you
kidding me you're not even I got Mark
Wahlberg so did you guys spend any time
you get a grown up we live together so
if I'm going to guess I do have an idea
my name is Elizabeth South I'm a private
investigator here in Los Angeles
California with cane associates
investigations today I am going to have
to figure out which two of these people
in the lineup are actually cousins
I'm guessing they don't look alike so
it's gonna really fool me but I don't
know let's see maybe you girls could be
related maybe you guys just sit down all
right
so cousin how are you related
moms dads other sisters our parents are
first cousins yes well you never know it
could be second or third no you're right
you're right you're right somebody step
displaced remarried no first cousins
your parents are related yeah which
parents my dad your dad in your mom yeah
all right so uh have you guys spent a
lot of time together when you raised
together tell me about your time in your
cousin hood we actually didn't grow up
near each other because I was in New
York are you just the quiet type I have
to like pull everything out of you are
you gonna add anything um I agree with
that I grew up in New Jersey and then at
15 I moved to the Bay Area sure sure
I wanna see if you're lying or not okay
the bay area okay I'm gonna switch out
some people here why don't you go back
up there will you stay here he comes
you guys may be cousins tell me about
how you'd be related definitely our
parents yeah mom said yeah it was really
bad at this aren't you no I'm really
good at this because we're cousins
yeah so your mom's side right mom's
what'd you say father yeah okay her
brother yeah so
where is he from we've seen each other
like twice I want to say no I don't know
you don't know we're close Connecticut
yeah Rachel you can say back up I love
you alright come sit down here you are
really good at this you are yeah have
you guys spent a lot of time you don't
know we didn't grow up in the same place
how are you guys related my mom and his
mom so how do you guys know your cousins
do you guys both live here explain me
how this works
yeah we both live here now but we didn't
just some chrome together but it's just
great we get to spend a lot of time
together now so where does she live in
LA
she lives in Culver City Culver City
what particles are sitting closer to
here so tell me about when you guys hang
out what's it like what do you go well
we work together mostly we get sick of
each other
whoever's cousins I've interviewed you
all yet you don't seem to like each
other very much do you like right why
don't you go back up there and sir you
come sit down here how could it keep you
here you're like my truth are you guys
related yes it was parents my dad he's
dead how many siblings is your mom about
three three siblings no what about yours
three yeah oh how convenient so both of
your parents have three siblings how'd
you guys meet up in LA I came out here
to acting school and I was doing alright
for a little bit and then he came out
here and then started doing well really
fast are you an actor to them no I'm
actually out of there you're an editor
okay
and so how long ago did you move out
here six years ago how long did you move
out here seven years ago so did you guys
spend any time you got a grown up we
live together oh I forgot this I left
out a big detail they were riding with
me he lived never mind yo you have to
tell me oh you know I was gonna do bikes
for a long time now that is the most
fascinating thing I think I've heard
from you all day
alright let's switch out once you go
stand up there you come back down here I
like you so much you
your friends I know why not really I'm
just using you all right go ahead now
what you grow up Massachusetts
Massachusetts what city Massachusetts
Boston I consider myself a Bostonian all
right because you know you don't really
have that strong of an accent oh no I
mean my parents aren't from Boston so I
feel like I kind of adopted there and
I've lived here for a while how long
have you lived in LA about six years you
are the first person who's ever lost
their accent from Boston that I've ever
met you grew up there yeah say this word
CA our car
it's kah I'd get from Boston are you
kidding me you're not even I got Mark
Wahlberg how many siblings did you wrong
enough she has four for 10 years has
three his mom is related to my dad their
brother-sister so I wouldn't he move out
here I think like six years ago around
the same time I did so you moved I heard
the same time about the same time around
yeah and what did she look now she lives
in Culver City too we're in colors day
closer to Palms
you know Chandler honestly I'm just kind
of using you right now because I don't
think related to anybody
gotcha I mean you may be but nobody that
I feel like I've put you with okay so
let's put you out let's bring you over
here show cousins yes all right
and besties true besties all right okay
so mother father father father mother
what's her father's name John where she
grew up she grew up in a San Francisco
in the San Francisco in San Francisco
please cuz you said in the San Francisco
it's like in the Ohio State University
yeah what part is name friend packets
I have no pack I don't pack guys you
know like feel off the off of the main
drag there oh really
okay um so why don't you go back up
there Rachel come down here all right so
it would be her mother
and what's her father's name Bruce
because I thought it was Jonathan what's
it doing to him yeah that's what that
dude said Bruce okay what's her mom's
name
Bethany Bethany what Bethany Hamlin um
go stand back up there you come down
here
relation please my mother your mother
and my mother and your mother all right
what's your mom's name her mom's name is
Emily Emily what Emily Luther
Emily Lutheran and
Stephanie Luther so she's not married I
mean it was single mom are they divorced
yeah when did they get divorced it's
been a while now probably five years
yeah about that I think mmm it's like
right after I graduated college how
often do you guys I mean did you grow up
and spend a lot of time together
no where's she from but she's from here
from LA okay where's she from
she is from Michigan well fried Michigan
Detroit so we're at Detroit Metro
Detroit so Troy here yeah what college
did she go - she went to UCLA and what
college did she go to USC and so when
did you guys you guys moved out here
what times right when I was going to
college yeah did you guys have you lived
together here in LA all guys hang out
very much we're starting to now yeah
definitely I think since my parents
divorce I kind of like lost kind of a
sense the family like a weird way so she
was like really supportive of that
well that wasn't real that's really cute
and I'm kind of a problem with me as a
PA I do get very empathetic like oh
really oh my god that would suck I've
experienced that before so kind of me
over I should get like really cold you
guys like to hang out usually when we
hang out we like get dinner at either
someone's apartment really go out like
[ __ ] every couple of months here so we
can wears last night you guys went out
it was like definitely to get drinks
yeah there's oh I think last time we
went is across the street yeah
from here yeah yeah yeah I don't know if
you guys are cousins but at least
believe you guys are friends maybe but
you play really well off that I've been
tricked before like let me um have you
go stand back up there and sir why don't
you come down here you are so polite
mother fathers my mom sisters I have a
feeling you just have a problem like
just saying exactly what it is maybe
you're like an earthy nocturnal
all right well where did he grow up uh
here in LA
really what part of Hawaii well
originally Hollywood for a bit like
LaBrea and
huh LaBrea and the breakup and sunset no
that's where I lived and then I grew up
over in Studio City at Waterville it
does not add water village I don't know
if you're just a nervous kind of a guy
Harley yeah I'm kind of getting now like
I feel like hell D right now I'm at 35
yeah you're just a nervous answer okay
I'm getting all right what's your mom's
name uh Hilary
really Hilary Hilary 1 Hilary sessions
ok well now that's funny cuz I got a
different name from her so I can't
answer for what the other person says
that's true what's his dad's name Barry
what college did he go - he went to UCLA
and where she from Michigan well prayer
Michigan I'm really bad at any kind of
geography why don't you go stand back up
there you wanted to come down here
really what's up cuz
all right parents related house mother
mother sisters and where's she from
I'm she's from here from LA mmm well
part of La originally from Westchester
and I live in Culver City and how long
ago did she move here she moved here
just after college so like four years
good do you guys hang out a lot yeah
actually I mean meeting out a lot at
work but we also have like the same
friends oh well that's convenient and
where's the last place you guys went
over our friend just had a housewarming
party in k-town she just moved our suite
out there did you guys see each other
growing up now because we're really too
far away I mean maybe like a few times
hmm but you've never seen each other
before like in person we'd seen each
other yeah like when we were kids I
think we had a reunion in like 2005 yeah
well you guys do seem kind of convincing
honestly I don't know but you know you
may not be related and you may just have
a very angelic face and be really good
at lying and looking at somebody for
clues all right let me get out some
other people you two are feeling likely
to me but you know you may just be
friends
let's have switch out
I already I don't think you took you
guys together so you guys stand back up
there oh don't even don't even think I'm
just gonna believe everything who's
parents my mom and his dad all right
what's your mom's name Hillary Hillary
mrs. Johnson
Andy Andy all right and so well where's
he from Sanford's call you Krupp in San
Francisco but then you moved when you're
like 10 to New York hmm we're in New
York Long Island
[Music]
[Laughter]
Rachel come sit down here where is she
from New York why I think she was
actually from Long Island
how old were you guys when you first met
each other I want to say that when we
met like you wouldn't ever remembered
because I think it was like my cousin
Erin's wedding and so I was like yeah
where was Erin's wedding I was like one
when did she move here like five years
ago and so when did you guys become
friends like hook up here and start
hanging out well she helped me get my
job here have wait all these two
together I don't think so
when she moved here two years mm-hmm
what do you guys go out and hang out
together really to go eat yeah that's
like her thing what's your favorite kind
of food she likes salads a lot so
where's the last place you ate three
green well you know you guys do work
together so I could use a little easily
believe that have you been to her house
at all to her apartment oh yes and
what's her mom's name
her mom's amis Evelyn what's her Sally
Sally really I'm just not really buying
you guys together
I don't know maybe you guys are alright
guys go ahead and stand out from all of
these names and people and putting it
together today like my head is spinning
like I have to say my brain is totally
fried right now so if I'm going to guess
I do have an idea I'm definitely not
feeling like totally solid on it but I
feel like it's my best guess with what I
the time I've had the thing about about
this is you do have people here who you
know obviously have worked together who
work together they're friends so they
can draw from a lot of real experience
but I do feel like there's been some
real interactions and the two people
that I feel are cousins that I've chosen
obviously I feel like have spent some
time together and know a bit about each
other can you come sit down here now I
talked with with these two people these
two girls right here and I kind of felt
like one of them may be your cousin can
you come sit over here okay are you guys
cousins
[Music]
[Laughter]
I spent a lot of time together and you
can tell that you guys are giving
genuine interaction and really answers
together now the thing is like it is
really hard to tell when you're telling
the truth because all of your answers
are a little bit like it it's kind of
hard to tell with you honey I didn't do
all the time I totally I totally believe
that Rachel II surprised me you really
got me you should feel good today that
was a really tough one because this guy
right here it's really hard to tell when
he's telling the truth or not he always
says it's like eating grin on his face
like you know the cat that ate the mouse
like I'm like well it could be him there
could be not him
[Music]